[Music]  it's so beautiful  after decades Julia Roberts is still  everyone's favorite pretty woman People  magazine has named Roberts to 2017 a  world's most beautiful woman marking the  actresses fifth time earning the title  here's Roberts covering the issue for  the first time in 1991 we think she's  never looked better  why do you keep going back to her she's  better looking now that she ever has  been she looks great and she also just  gets better in life now she's in this  very very happy marriage he's got three  great kids and she's carved out this  really simple perfect private life  inside the mag the ageless star says  she's currently peaking in life and  gushed about her 14-year marriage to  husband Danny I'm just glad I found him  you  [Music]